PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Welcome
to get Cooking in Cloud,
where we share the best recipes
to apply in your cloud kitchen.
I'm Priyanka, and
in this episode,
we'll share the recipe
to plan a warm DR
pattern for your application
that are deployed on premise.
So let's dive in.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
A little recap.
In the last episode, we were
talking about Main Street art
that runs through
applications on premise
and our building a DR
infrastructure on Google Cloud.
And we helped them
set up a cold DR plan.
Well, Main Street art has
changed a bit since then.
They now need to setup a
warm stand by DR pattern
to keep the RTO and
RPO values as small as
possible without the effort
and expense of a fully
HA configuration, which
means to support a disaster,
they need some
replication and redundancy
built into the system.
Well, let's see how
this would work.
We create a VPC network, then
we configure the connectivity
between the on-premise network
and the Google Cloud network.
We replicate the on-premise
servers to the Compute Engine
instances, then create snapshots
of the web and application
server instances.
We then create a custom
image of the database server
on Google Cloud with the same
configuration as on premise.
Then we start a database
instance in Google Cloud using
that custom image and
attach a persistent disk
to the instance for database
and transaction logs,
configure the replication
of the database server,
set auto delete flag
on the persistent disk
to no auto delete.
We do this so that our
persistent disk will not
be inadvertently deleted since
that would be a disaster,
configure a scheduled
task to create
regular snapshots of the
persistent disk of the database
instance on Google Cloud, then
test the process of creating
instances from the snapshots
by creating the web
and application server, also
create a script that copies
updates to the web application
and the application server
whenever the corresponding
on-premise servers are updated,
write the script to create
a snapshot of the updated
service, then configure
Cloud DNS to point
to the internet-facing
web service on premise.
Then a disaster hits.
All Main Street art needs to
do is to resize the database
server instance to handle
the production load,
use the web and application
server snapshots to create
new web and application
server instances
and then test that it all works.
Once tested, point the Cloud
DNS to their web service
on Google Cloud.
When the production environment
is running on premise again
and can support
production workloads,
Main Street art has to
reverse the steps that they
followed during the failover.
A typical sequence to return
to the production environment
is we take a backup of the
database running on Google
Cloud, then copy and apply the
backup files to the database
in the production environment.
Then we prevent connections
to the application
in Google Cloud.
One way to do this is to prevent
connections to the web server
by modifying the firewall rules.
From this point, the
application will be unavailable
until we finish restoring
the production environment.
Don't forget to copy any
transaction log files over
to the production
environment and apply
to the database in
that environment.
Test that the application
works as expected
by simulating the user scenarios
on the production environment.
Configure Cloud DNS to point
to the on-premise web service,
then delete the web
server and the application
server instances that are
running in Google Cloud,
resends the database
server on Google Cloud back
to the minimum
instance size that
can accept replicated data
from the on-premise production
database, then
configure replication
between on-premise
database server
and the database
server in Google Cloud
by following the instructions
for your specific database
software.
Well, there you have it.
If you are running your
application on premise and need
to keep the RTO and RPO
values as small as possible
without the expense of a
fully HA configuration,
then a warm DR pattern
is the way to go.
We learned how to
approach recovering
the environment from failure
in a warm DR scenario.
That's all for today on
Get Cooking in Cloud.
I'm hoping you're cooking
up your own DR strategy.
Join us next time where
we will share the recipe
to implement a hot DR pattern.
If you like this video and would
like to see more such content,
don't forget to like and
subscribe to our channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]